welcome to this video yeah this is a new
serious IAM on my channel it's about
endgame strategy one of the new series
that I'm that I'm launching it has no
one planned and to it it's not like
there are ten parts or anything I'm just
kicking off with one example and I'm
going to continue with with new
positions each week every two weeks I
don't know I'm going to mix it up on the
channel okay and gave a strategy what
does this mean actually yeah what I'm
thinking about is endgame positions or
endgame close to endgame positions where
there are still some pieces on the board
positions that cannot be classified as
as basic and games where there is a
clear known scientific solution to it
like King and pawn against King where
there is a clear clear results normally
it's just a position that is played out
and has endgame characteristics um yeah
let's um start with this example this is
the game kappa blanka with white against
heart attack over from new york 1924 on
the main point of this game arises after
move 30 but I'm still going to go very
quickly through the moves before that to
get a feel what was going on I think
this is very often a good idea not
looking at the critical position but
also get an idea what happened in the
game yeah we had a Dutch defense kappa
blanka is just developing pieces
naturally here with Bishop g5 nothing
fancy yeah and we see a number of very
normal-looking moves which attack over
plays Queen to e8
yeah very often this is an idea getting
the Queen over for activity Queen e2 and
94 this simplifying maneuver yeah after
Bishop e7 he flicked in this
to me you'd move with an attack on the
Queen so white needs to recapture first
Queen takes yeah and I think this
position is about about equal why this
may be a bit more comfortable due to a
space advantage but it's nothing special
this capture on f3 is a bit as an
original solution giving up the bishop
here for the night
but what he wants to do is he wants to
get this Knight to a5 and maybe attack
the pawn on c4 however there is not much
it's not a big chance that black is
going to win the pond with this kind of
idea it is safely protected and white
will always have ideas with a form but
okay let's see what happens yeah kappa
blanka is playing f4 here interesting
move blocking any 65 ideas right a 5 and
he's going back and d6 now yeah what
white wants to do is to play a fall and
he does so here to open up the e-file
and put some pressure of the e6 pawn the
rook is protecting though or both ropes
are protecting the pawn the whole thing
here is yeah maybe a bit more
comfortable for white but there's
nothing terrible yet that black has done
you've got some strengthening moves g3
that's a very typical preparation move
it supports the pawn on f4 and it might
prepare h4 h5 which is a typical way to
make some headway on the Kings side yeah
black is just shuffling a bit while
widest advancing still nothing terrible
happened d5 and interesting and maybe a
slightly debatable move black is in a
way losing its patience his patience and
opens up the position also in the
process allowing white to get rid of his
double porn
we now have those piece trades which was
obviously the idea that Tata Cova had he
wanted to track defend trying by
simplification however in this position
it is quite apparent that this Bishop on
these three is now a pretty good piece
yeah it has some effect both on the
Queen side and on the Kings side the
King side part is more yeah more
important of course because of this move
this pawn break here h5 attacking the g6
pawn and putting pressure on the Kings
side
YTN it's definitely a little bit better
he can attack this weakness on g6 well
black has no clear counter attacking
idea however is defending well Luke f6
defending this weakness from the side
Thapa Blanca captures and now occupies
the OpenEdge file King f8 yeah this is
designed to keep the keep the pawn here
protected rook h7 attacking on the
seventh rank very important motif of
course and rook c6 Black is setting up a
counter attack on the c3 pawn so we
actually managed to initiate a counter
play g4 why does advancing on the King
side he's got two parts against one pawn
so he should use his advantage there
where the other moves
yes rook d7 was also a good move the
g-force is perfectly okay
Knight c4 was played like also has
alternatives he can play Knight b3 for
example
initiating maybe also this move but the
main point of all this is coming later 9
c4
ng5 that's very important
why does not trying to play f5 here to
get a passed pawn which would be okay
huh the past pawn is nice to have but it
also would help like to get rid of his
weakness on g6 what white wants to do us
with g5 wants to fix this weakness on g6
this weakness is now permanent and
always needs some attention like is
showing this this check on e3 King f3
and now we come to a very critical
position in this game how should black
play
his Knight is attacked on a three and it
obviously has to move there is no
alternative to that and the night only
has two really sensible squares it can
go to f5 or to d1 and it turns out that
tatacoa went to f5 and this is in fact a
very substantial mistake what you should
have done is to play Knight to d1 and
try to get get this pawn with the night
the whole situation after that is also a
bit better for white but it is still a
position that black can try to defend
for example King e2 and attacking this
Knight track here King d2 and yeah here
Knight a four it's not possible so
probably ninety four is going to be
played and we get this type of endgame
where black and try to try to fight at
least white is better but it's it's a
fight he went to f5 and now we come to
the very instructive part of this game
how does some kappa blanka continue here
yeah he decided to capture the noise
G takes f and now this is the the the
main the main point of this this classic
example this rook endgame example the
interesting point is White has the Jeep
on very important passport very
dangerous passport but how does he
actually make progress it's not so easy
if you just want to play with the Jeep
on like energy six years just blundering
the pawn but you know you the thing is
you cannot win with the Jeep on and the
rook on your own you're never going to
promote the pawn what Wyatt needs is
support by the king and he plays the
move came 2 G 3 that is very very strong
he allows the black rook to capture on
c3 Jack that happened and now King h4
and the important thing is white now has
a very substantial threat and idea g6
and the King invasion what should like
do now he played in the game he played
rook f3 are there alternatives black and
also tried to defend differently what
happens if he plays rook c6 we should
start with this trying to block the G
part for the moment right then plays
King age 5 note that white is a pawn
down but this is not have not really a
relevant here those parts for example
they don't they don't pose any threat
they are just fixed on their squares and
white has a very concrete idea he wants
to get in with the King or play g6 King
g5 King takes f5 the King activity is
qiam rukuh c6 is absolutely not
sufficient for defense in the game you
played look f3 but what else is there he
could try to play a six maybe this is
maybe a somewhat tougher defense a6 b5
trying to use the b-pawn and
souls of counterplay if we check now
what should why do there are two basic
ways to play you can play g6 or you can
invade with the king
let's say you and wait with the King
King age five
now important this this is not leading
anywhere of course the Jeep on just
promotes so black should push beehive
that was the idea we capture and go King
g6 trying to capture this pawn before
Jack Jack King seven makinia five and in
this position white has there was two
connected passes supported by the king
while black is is not so quick he only
has the B point basically he does not
have connected pawns y-term should win
this position maybe continue a bit too
to illustrate the point jack and now
maybe King G find f5 all start with g6
also possible g6 and sp3 may be ok let's
let's stop the pawn for the moment
rook b6 root B 3 kingi 7 kingi 4 and now
we are going to go into advanced King F
for King e5 the protected passes are
much more dangerous than a single pass
pawn on the be found still maybe this
was a tougher defense a6 and b5
Tata Cooper went as mentioned look to f3
attacking the pawn and what cannot
defend the pawn so what did he do of
course g6 going for activity black
together with the rook with check King
g5 and now rookie for yeah why just
sacrifice two pawns don't forget that
but he's got this clear invasion idea
the look is attacked on a form if he
takes on default let's start with that
white wins immediately with King f6 it's
very important that
cause right is not capturing this pawn
this pawn is not important in the moment
at the moment you want to play King f6
with a direct made threat setting up
this this attack on the king
yeah and now black has absolutely no
defense if you place te 8 for example we
are already talking about the mate
absolutely unavoidable and yeah King yet
we give us check and then simply promote
the poly very important not take the
pawn always think twice in in Ruka and
games if you have the alternative to
capture pawn or to get an active
position on the six rank with the King
and mating attack with the King always
consider that the activity is far more
important than than material gains in
fact in this position if white captures
this is a gross mistake because of rooks
e4 when any advance on the six rank is
answered by the check and this is not
winnable for what white cannot win this
position he can draw due to the activity
but he cannot win anymore it's very
important okay
went here King e4 and again in this
position what should white play it's
absolutely important
then white is not capturing the F pawn
but play King of six
this is scheme the King activity
invading blacks position setting up a
mating attack combined with the Jeep on
if you take on f5 black is going to take
and now you cannot win he again has this
defense on the six rank or he is able to
give this check from the back this is
also a reason why keeping this kind of
pawn it's sometimes referred to as the
umbrella this is the umbrella pawn
because the rain
in checks that happen on f4 are blocked
by the umbrella on f5 very very funny
description but it's it's a very it's
very nice to to to have this kind of
label attached to something can more
easily record it if you if you have it
on the game so the King activity counts
not capture the pawn okay Ruka h8 is the
threat Black has supply King g8 there's
nothing nothing else really Jack White
gives this chick king here yeah if he
goes to f8 we are going to going to take
him threatening rook c8 and we have a
position that it's very very similar to
this rook e8 needed to be done there was
rook c8 threatened it's a meeting attack
all those squares are controlled and
nuke c8 made us the threat yeah and only
now when the black rook was forced to
get to this passive position on the edge
only now we take on f5 and if we take
stock it's equal material the Dwight
enjoys this fantastic pawn and
especially the rook on the 7th rank to
h7 actually yeah this is not defensible
yeah threatening made again check check
GD 5 here Jack White is using his big
space advantage so that he can play g7
yeah the d5 pawn would fall in case of a
ruptured Tata cover plate this one of
course if he allows this white is taking
here and simply wins the King and pawn
endgame something like this on a 6 King
c-65 take take and white will promote
the D pawn so King g8 and now we just
take everything who took a 7
King takes d5 note that white started
the rook end game with first one pawn
down then two points down but his
superior activity allowed him to gain so
much material that he now is two pawns
up and it's not only to pause it's the
fantastic activity the rook on the
seventh the D pawn and so this is lost
data : played a couple of more moves but
it was in vain here the deep onus is
decisive Black has no way to stop this
pawn simply d7 rook c8 and d8 Queen
coming so what's the big point of of
this game activity in the rook endgame
Jack here King G 3 H 4 g5 f 6 this is
key
why does activating the king and he's
not interested in in this material on
the Queen side he once I activated the
King and use it in connection with this
rook on the 7th the second is very
important motive is the umbrella upon
not take the pod here but advanced right
into blacks position and make sure that
there are no defensive checks coming
from the back very often this is the
right approach
if you have this far advanced pawn the
6th rank and the active rook not take
this pawn but keep it down to serve as
an umbrella umbrella against the bank
the checks from the back so very
instructive rook endgame example and I
hope a nice kickoff for this new series
I hope you enjoyed it and yeah make sure
to watch the channel there will be new
content every day besides the Blitz
games I will feature other things daily
thanks for watching